King Henrik I mean his name speaks for
itself you see what he's done in New
York and the kind of player he is on and off
the eyes he was the one you you looked up to
he was one of the greatest a l got there in
time HRI is one of the most famous athletes
in Swedish history 2012 best trophy
Henrik lumus one of the big reasons
why I became a goalie feels amazing so we're
going to show you a couple highlights of his
here yeah there it is he makes the Superman
save there with with the stick out of this
world oh my
God it's an insane save save by
that's that's a crazy save yeah I
mean I don't know he stopped it he has
such a good hockey IQ he knew where to
be in The N he never gives up on any
moment back hands in there you have
it congrats Henrik well deserved honor of
him getting picked into the Hockey Hall of
Fame